lawmakers in Nashville have been under
pressure to tighten gun laws after last
week's deadly school shooting there
protesters Phil the Tennessee house
chamber one week ago and at one point
Democratic legislators led a chant from
the floor using a bullhorn now the
Republicans who control the house are
responding with an almost unprecedented
move to expel those three Democrats Mark
Strassman is in Nashville Mark good
morning
good morning Vlad this is bare knuckle
partisan politics a possible vote by a
republican super majority here to throw
out three Democratic state
representatives they were disruptive and
it can cost them
[Applause]
[Music]
three Democratic Tennessee State
lawmakers who protested with a bull horn
during a legislative session now face
possible retribution from a republican
super majority a vote to remove them
from office when you realize that they
were serious about expulsion 1.3 a month
um it's outrageous one of those state
representatives Gloria Johnson so if the
expulsion goes through what kind of a
message does it send
well it's since a a terrifying message
to me that we are we are losing
democracy
foreign
the Nashville shooting and the gun
debate in Tennessee have sent shock
waves across the country yesterday
thousands of students fed up with gun
violence walked out of schools they say
don't feel safe
it
makes you concerned if you're going to
be next Nashville Mourns those six lives
cut short including Catherine Koontz the
head of the Covenant School
she was incredibly strong Anna cuddle
was a close friend police say Koontz
heard gunshots and likely tried to stop
the shooter there was some confrontation
I'm sure he can tell the way she was
laying in the hallway her priority would
have been
to save the kids even at risk to herself
already would have been everyone
in danger in that moment without
reservation
the three-state lawmakers have already
been stripped of their committee
assignments if they are expelled they
could run for their seats again in his
special election Nate
we will stay tuned mark thank you